no se están pidiendo que factor hicimos
20 x al cuadrado por b menos 10 por x b
cuadrada ok ya lo que se refieren cuando
nos piden que factor hicimos es a que
tomemos este binomio o cualquier
expresión que nos está impidiendo que
factor hicimos y lo escribamos como un
producto de otras dos expresiones
entonces vamos a ver si podemos hacer
eso y la forma más fácil de hacerlo es
encontrar factores comunes entre las
expresiones que se están sumando o
restando de hecho sabes que es mejor
tomar el máximo común divisor de todos
los términos y después aplicar algo que
sería así como la inversa de la
propiedad distributiva que básicamente
es dividir a cada uno de los términos
entre el máximo común divisor y después
multiplicar a todo por el mismo máximo
común divisor que es lo que estamos
factor izando de esta expresión vas a
ver a qué me refiero en unos cuantos
segundos por lo pronto empecemos por
encontrar el máximo común divisor de
estos dos términos
entonces por lo menos al principio hay
que escribir cada uno de estos términos
en su expresión más sencilla lo que hay
buscando las partículas más elementales
que componen a esta multiplicación el
vídeo pasado se trataba de eso entonces
vamos a hacerlo un poquito más rápido
aquí 20 x al cuadrado por b si lo
queremos escribir lo más desarrollado
posible lo escribimos como 20 en su
factor y zación en primos que es
simplemente 2 por 2 por 5 por la
cuadrada son 2 es multiplicándose
entonces aquí ponemos un x
y finalmente por ve y de este lado
tenemos aquí 10 cuya factorización en
primos es 2 por 5 una sola u una sola y
tenemos dos veces multiplicándose
entonces b por b muy bien ahora vamos a
encontrar el máximo común divisor de
estos dos términos entonces saber los
dos términos tienen un 2 entonces vamos
a circular lo aquí podría circular
cualquiera de estos dos los dos tienen
un 5
los dos tienen por lo menos una a este
término tiene dos sus pero este término
sólo tiene uno entonces sólo vamos a
circular una y los dos tienen por lo
menos una vez chica
y entonces aquí tenemos que el máximo
común divisor es 2 x 5 x o por b y
entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
escribir a cada uno de estos términos
como nuestro máximo común divisor por
alguna otra expresión ok pero vamos a
aplicar el inverso de la propiedad
distributiva de una vez por todas aquí
este término es el máximo común divisor
que son todos estos cuatro círculos
naranjas por dos por uno entonces vamos
a poner por aquí 2 x y de este lado este
término es el máximo común divisor por b
entonces a la hora de aplicar la
propiedad distributiva en este
paréntesis con este factor lo que nos
queda es este por este que es este
término de aquí menos el máximo común
divisor por b que es este término de acá
entonces estas dos expresiones son
exactamente iguales
además ya hicimos lo que nos están
pidiendo ya lo escribimos como una
multiplicación de dos cosas nuestro
máximo común divisor y de este
paréntesis y para terminar deberíamos de
simplificar este término
entonces nos queda 2 por 5 10 y aquí
tenemos una y una vez
por 2 a 2 o menos
y pues aquí nos tomamos la molestia de
poner todos los factores de cada uno de
estos términos porque estamos empezando
pero lo que uno hace normalmente ya que
entendió que es lo que estamos haciendo
en el fondo es tomar estas expresiones y
calcularlo mentalmente cuál es el máximo
común divisor aunque ahí vamos a hacerlo
y entonces uno dice ah tenemos 20 y
tenemos 10 y el 10 divide al 20 entonces
el máximo común divisor entre 20 y 10
tiene que ser un 10 y por aquí tenemos
un cuadrada
y el máximo común divisor de estos dos
entonces tiene que ser una u y el máximo
común divisor entre b y b cuadrada es
una vez entonces este es el máximo común
divisor entre estos dos términos y
entonces vamos a multiplicar el máximo
común divisor por 20 por cuadrada por b
pero vamos a dividir este término entre
nuestro máximo común divisor que
10 v y después tenemos menos el otro
término que es 10 por o por b cuadrada
pero también lo vamos a dividir entre el
máximo común divisor 10 x o por b que
entonces lo que tenemos aquí si
aplicamos la propiedad distributiva nos
queda este por éste pero entonces éste
se va a cancelar con este y nos va a
quedar simplemente el primer término que
es el término morado y después lo
tenemos que restar este por esto pero
entonces se va a cancelar este con este
y nos va a quedar simplemente el
numerador que es el segundo término
así es que claramente estas dos
expresiones son iguales
ok pero esta expresión de aquí se puede
simplificar más porque estas expresiones
racionales tienen factores comunes de
hecho su factor común es 10 por 1 por b
pero bueno entonces tenemos aquí 20
entre 10
y de eso nos queda simplemente 12 y por
aquí tenemos cuadrada entre 1 y nos
queda simplemente
a la vez se cancela con la ve ya eso le
tenemos que restar 10 entre 10 es
simplemente un 1
esto es equivalente a decir que se
cancelan entre wood es otro 1 y b
cuadrada entre b nos queda simplemente
una b por uno por uno que es simplemente
una vez y listo ya terminamos aquí y
obtuvimos exactamente lo mismo aunque
hay factor izamos esta expresión como 10
por 1 por b por entre paréntesis 2 - b